watch this video this is this is really
incredible like if you want like the
most perfect example of virtually
everything that I talk about on this
show how the mainstream media laanders
the lies and how they work with the
Democrat Party so that when you see
something right in front of you that you
know it's true that right now who is
responsible for the Border like let's
just pause here for a sec who's
responsible for the Border it's the
president of the United States right
that is one of the few things that the
federal government is supposed to do so
we just showed you those videos all of
these people are coming across I don't
think anyone is doubting the numbers
right with these insane border crossings
I think over 2 million this year so that
is the fault of the Democrat Party and
the president these are just facts you
may not like them
but they are facts and by the way if it
was a Republican president and this was
happening then it would be the fault of
the Republican president but listen to
the way ABC's Martha raddatz raises this
question related to whose fault it is
that all these people are coming and
then you'll really get insight into how
they trick people from not being able
they basically say look that's right in
front of you no no that's not what you
see it's something else this is it's an
incredible shell game watch this you
talk about the border wall you talk
about open borders I don't think I've
ever heard
President Biden say we have an open
board come on over but people I have
heard said for you
our former president Trump or Ron
DeSantis
that message
reverberates
in Mexico and Beyond so they do get the
message that it is an open order and
Smugglers use all those kinds of
statements it was it was known for the
time that Joe Biden got elected Joe
Biden supported open borders it is known
by the cartels they have sophisticated
information whether or not the body
Administration is going to enforce the
immigration laws or not is known across
the world but most importantly known
among the cartels and how do you play
into that what can you do better so we
have every level of government doing
everything we can to prevent people from
coming into the country illegally or
repelling them or arresting them and
putting them behind bars do you see what
she just did there do you see what she
just did that was obviously Texas
governor Greg Abbott so she's saying to
Greg Abbott who has all these Texas
border towns right she's saying because
you guys say that Biden has an open
border that's why people are coming not
because Biden's actions have proven it
so she's trying to blame the people who
are calling out the problem for the
problem itself she's saying well Joe
Biden never said it yes of course Joe
Biden never said guys we have an open
border come on down right like this is
Price is Right come on down spin the
wheel get the cash that's in essence
what we're doing but she didn't uh Biden
actually never flat outside it but she
completely flips the reality that's what
I mean about the shell game that it's
not Biden who says open borders it's you
guys who are not in charge of the Border
it's you Greg Abbott it's you Ron to say
this it's you Donald Trump and that's
what the migrants the migrants the
illegal aliens that's what they hear and
that's why they're coming it's such an
extraordinary subtle uh pernicious
Distortion of the truth uh gross
disgusting but this is what they do to
all Republicans and you must know this